[Music]
and not worth it news nope
you know what's not worth it submitted
by El Nino what's that le Mignot I don't
know that's like El Nino but the men
maybe whose names Manuel oh I thought it
said Manuel like like manual or the
person that's American just be a
stupidest [ __ ] oh I don't know then
el menudo there you go
work barriers on a cruise ship had to
stop a desperate screaming passenger
from jumping off to save her phone oh my
god [ __ ] off she was gonna jump off
those slow jump oh my good oh she find
it in the ocean
plink but you guys don't know maybe
she's a secret agent and there was some
very important stuff in that dump in
there like documents but she needs it to
complete a case make an airdrop in your
was fine I've seen this in James 1
million times that's crazy the oceans
explain afterwards I don't think I give
a [ __ ] about my phone and after that I
break it on purpose anyways I've seen
you yeah so there's really I don't think
oh yeah just whatever do [ __ ] it turn
off your phone you are so strange with
your phone either you abuse it or you
just leave it somewhere for like days
and I can't get a hold of you this is
true you know what I did for I not to
like I'm very careless now I left my
credit card at a fun restaurant Oh for
like four days I don't even know you
know but then I go there all the time so
they held it for me and they're like you
didn't get a new one yet because I came
back four days later I think yeah
and they gave it back to you leaves
boxes everywhere to actually us
eyeglasses I can't find my other one
I've lost those recently they're like
Cinderella [ __ ] everywhere yeah so this
lady actually they we got her right the
reason why she wanted to go get her
phones because there were important
documents what kind of important
pictures that he took for her boy she
don't know what a clowder
probably the best [ __ ] pics that she
had as she knows that her [ __ ] will
never look at that ever again
though that's a great deer I should take
photos on [ __ ] pictures like a young
[ __ ] do you realize what's gonna happen
in the comments right now talking about
her cat Gina - so anyway she's just too
young [ __ ] to shave' yes this woman
uh her surname Lou hey that's really
nice so you ie you li you Chinese
Chinese yeah Chinese so this was in
China she was on a cruise ship and like
over this lake like a really big lake
that's why she wanted a jump they do
cruises that oh it's a lake a deep lake
a 23-foot deeply ah that's like an ocean
of 20 that's pretty shy lad 43 feet yes
remember when we were snorkeling and
then the gold hole fell inside the water
but we were on a boat though and it was
really deep and we try to dive yeah it
was Bart's GoPro and then it was hurting
our ears trying to get it and then we
asked the guy diver guy the pressure
with no oxygen either 8:23 he just
jumped in oh he's a free driver that's
is a feat I remember you guys went us
new buying right yeah how deep did you
guys go I have no idea that's probably
15 20 feet it's when you have like oh
and you're connected by a hose so they
went snooping and I was really curious
so I went down to where they were at -
it was cool and I was like 15 20 feet
but whatever wherever the camera fell it
was so it was way more than I was like
50 60 feet oh really yeah
you also mention that so staff did go
into the lake try to find this woman's
phone but it was really hard because
there were it's 23 feet and it has a lot
of water we've
yeah but either way like she was just
[ __ ] hysterical and I'm sure you guys
a clip of her going hysterical like
people were holding her back to be maybe
I mean pictures of her baby what objects
and what if it was voice notes and
pictures of her like her parents that
passed away and don't worry she had left
I must think what the I'm mistake with
the Chinese [ __ ] pics but then but then
your phone isn't working anymore right
maybe wasn't waterproof but it's like
she's distraught yeah I like to think
she's a perfect she's a great swimmer
just because she's a woman doesn't mean
she can't dive and swim I think that
because I think people she was like you
guys better stop holding me back I'm a
professional moister diver I do this for
a living you [ __ ] sucks fishing and
crying yeah cuz they're not letting her
goal the first time I heard that phrase
did you [ __ ] sad such a [ __ ]
sacks of [ __ ] sucks of [ __ ] here we go
that sucks of shits Oh deep translate
that Bart can't even in translation
saying let me jump dive I'm a
professional you're not a professional
you're a woman I can't hear a poem time
what a male I mean that's a half a
sentence so it's like not gonna have it
anymore I don't know what your friend
what she said was Jews are sure about
stars there and then the guy says well
if you lose your life you're not gonna
have anything else anyways sexist
Chinese people why dr. gel why he
doesn't believe she can swim yeah so
they're saying that they're trying to
calm her down for the for a while so
then finally the company just dragged
her to safety and then they arranged for
a boat to come pick her up from the
cruise ship and then take her back to
shore and they put her into a white
jacket how come when I always see videos
of somebody over exaggerating to the max
like death drills it's always a Chinese
lady like it's never know like death
shrills no have you seen black people in
court when their son gets sent away to
go to jail that is legitimate things
that don't matter like an iPhone breaks
or yeah thank you I mean you know why
it's because a lot of people don't know
this but Asian girls they go through a
whole entire life
obeying and being good and being told
what to do and they can't take it
anymore and it just comes out and says
you [ __ ] I'm gonna dive and get
my phone because I know how to dive cuz
I like the way that surly black women
yell it's very whimsical and it's a lot
of attitude and sass huh it's like oh I
wish you would do something [ __ ]
cuz I swear if you put your hands on me
[ __ ] I'm gonna cut that ass up
do something [ __ ] it's so it's so like
a lot of times they just repeat the same
thing over and over again yeah it's so
tight though because like at least it's
not shrill cuz my mom was she
shrim God why you gotta break the glass
though come on cuz
Asian woman have a little bit of Bashi
in them you know pac-man she we're all
have man she Irish ghost yeah hmm I feel
bad why are you go sing those movies
never have accidents excuse me you just
said Irish ghosts and they don't have an
oh they don't have a huge essence the
ghost of Davy Jones doesn't he have one
dime on that's a because you'll be
laughing at the ghost first is not very
scary so even the veena musical has to
change his act like let's say this woman
cause your whole ship to be like delayed
you're like right there next year like
[ __ ] I really want to know what's on
that phone though like it like I was
there I would push everyone else back
let her jump
I want a sore ass jump over and record
it yeah that's okay captain everybody I
would make it seem like like I'm trying
to hold her back but no stop pushing me
so hard but in reality I actually threw
her off oh that goes Oh strong like tire
rope around her like a compromise like
if she wanted wants to jump give me that
[ __ ] broke tire ass up and then
tie it to this boat and then she just
tugs jump yeah and there's any talk can
we [ __ ] pull ass back up they should
have a scuba diving team for every
single boat
tried to look for her phone I mean like
on the boat wouldn't give someone falls
over I want to know what those documents
are are they [ __ ] pics are they baby
pics are they voicemails of your
deceased mother and father what is it if
it was a letter then I'd be like oh [ __ ]
I can't really do my Chinese what if she
was lying and there's no documents she
was like at the hardest level of
whatever [ __ ] game chiseling angry
Chinese woman who lost her eyesight
after spending days like looking at you
[ __ ] crazy about [ __ ] like that oh I
understand like were people who let
their babies die because they play video
games for like two weeks straight
that's you're wrong that's true yes and
the wrong people
I didn't app is there any inanimate
object that you would jump off a ship
for no question inanimate object
do you know what like sentimental values
is [ __ ] yeah anything what am i I might
even have a sentimental value milk a
might and the reason why is because the
sentimental value lives in here isn't
the memories so if I have something in
my grandpa gave me
it's [ __ ] dub is not a value attached
to it and I dropped it and it's gonna
it's not worth risking my life although
you know what my grandpa always gave me
that one thing and I remember what it
means say that same [ __ ] though in a
Confucius Taiwanese way yeah
when you lose a rock the rock disappear
[Laughter]
how like realistic is it to be able to
get it back
yeah cuz I think I'd say I think people
that are hysterical like they're stupid
yeah they think they can get it back
right but for me I'm like [ __ ] you like
this it'll it there's like there's like
a 50% chance that you could probably get
it back 50% oh yeah I'm gonna probably
went scuba right I'm going to snorkel in
Hawaii that's possible but we were on
that cruise ship and it's like just deep
blue and black no that's impossible
remember when Tommy losses GoPro and
those waves were crashing and he was we
were like just grab it dude you could do
it it in his eyes no it's dude Tommy man
all you gotta do is ask the lifeguard
just somebody will help you like no it's
all over and he was so sure that it was
over
and then we asked a lifeguard and he was
like okay let me try yeah and then the
lifeguard went in and he found it but he
goes any Krauts he stands up in these
waters away Susie's telling people to
get out of the water because it's some
neck breaking waves in the North Shore
the guy made it seem really easy he just
went in he's from national Waimea Bay or
whatever Waimea whatever [ __ ] but I
don't know man it's traumatic because I
left a hat on top of a shower thing in
Hawaii and then I only walked ten foot
ten steps and I went walking at the car
at the desolate where's your hat I was
like it was funny thing is if it was
like half a Snickers bar if I would have
back mmm not Snickers Twix yeah you told
me hey guys I hope you guys enjoy the
video please remember to give us a big
thumbs up and a like like like and also
when you guys sign on YouTube make sure
just kidding news is the first thing you
watch every single day because we post
videos every day okay for more videos